ces images vous risquez bien de les
revoir de les revivre prochainement car
dans les raffineries et des poupées
troliers la CGT vient de lancer un appel
à la grève contre la réforme des
retraites on appelle aussi à la
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales on peut faire grève il faut
aussi être attentif au quotidien de nos
concitoyens on est dans une période qui
peut être compliquée avec de
l'inquiétude notamment sur l'inflation
entre les installations sont arrêtées
mais effectivement il commence à y avoir
des
des impacts en termes
d'approvisionnement du pays en essence
sera les conséquences sur
l'approvisionnement à la pompe il y a
une opposition d'un certain nombre de
syndicats qui annoncent des mouvements
moi je veux pas résumer la situation en
face à face entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats je pense que l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller parler aux
Français c'est de convaincre les
Français du bien fondé de cette réforme
et en tout cas c'est ce à quoi je vais
mettre les a confirmé aujourd'hui qu'il
y aurait une revalorisation des petites
retraites pour un million 800
000 respecter et que les retraités qui
avaient une carrière complète aurait une
revalorisation de 100 euros donc c'est
un point de satisfaction important on
est dans le laxisme le plus complet avec
ces pays-là vous les reprenez sinon
c'est aucun visage on bloque les
transferts financiers on va voir
Bruxelles en leur disant vous arrêtez la
coopération économique et financière
avec ces pays mais oui il faut avoir un
peu de courage politique mais nos
dirigeants successifs non non
je suis pour le port de l'uniforme à
l'école mais avec une tenue simple et
pas tristoun notre phrase du jour
concerne l'école également et elle est
signée Brigitte Macron qui s'exprime
dans une longue interview parisien c'est
au tour du groupe de Marine Le Pen ne
défende ses propositions de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale cet après-midi et
sur la table l'obligation de porter
l'uniforme dans les écoles et les
collèges publics alors déjà ce sujet il
divise jusqu'à la majorité
présidentielle nostalgie du bon vieux
temps calmez-vous une un il n'y a jamais
eu d'uniforme à l'école publique en je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de hasard je crois
qu'il y a une opération de communication
de la part de Brigitte Macron qu'elle
est articulée au calendrier
parlementaire du rassemblement national
je crois que Brigitte Macron cherche à
exprimer des convergences de fond entre
le macronisme et le pénis cette
standardisation est une vieille lubie
éculée qui génère encore plus
d'exclusion 4 vous dirigez quel
ministère déjà madame c'est même pas
donc seul que vous m'interrogez en
vérité sur ce que pense madame Macron
malgré tout le respect que j'ai pour
cette dame tout à fait respectable il
n'est pas dans son rôle là non
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire une chose
pour un républicain elle n'a strictement
aucun rôle donc l'uniforme c'est
vraiment le gadget pour masquer en
réalité les inégalités il est vraiment
fâcheux que la première dame se prête à
ça je pense que je souhaiterais c'est
que la première dame puisse inciter les
parlementaires de la majorité de
d'Emmanuel Macron à voter ce texte il y
a un groupe de députés qui travaillent à
sa propre proposition sur le sujet ah
bah écoutez je me je m'en réjouis mais
ils ont l'occasion de le voter cet
après-midi et donc parce que ça
émanerait du rassemblement pour ça il ne
voudrait pas le voter nous n'étudions
pas les les textes qui sont proposés par
le RN donner votre compte jamais nous ne
voterons jamais les amendements du RN
c'est la frontière que nous mettons les
types ils sont contre parce que c'est le
rassemblement national mais comment on
peut être assez stupide Conan pour
pouvoir choisir de dire non uniquement
et te le disent ah c'est le
rassemblement national qui le propose
donc je peux pas voter pour et alors
pourquoi et je trouve que Madame Macron
je sais pas si elle a fait exprès ou pas
elle casse avec ça et tant mieux moi
donner la possibilité au chef
d'établissement ou aux parents d'élèves
il pourrait y avoir des consultations de
décider de la mise en place de
l'uniforme d'une tenue commune à
l'échelle de leur établissement dans un
premier temps en tout cas pourquoi pas
la proposition de loi que nous avons
étudié a donc été rejeté la proposition
de loi est rejetée la proposition de loi
est rejetée sur la cuisine elle dit ça
lui prend un temps infini pour faire les
courses parce qu'il parle avec tous les
commerçants oui ça c'est sûr que si
Emmanuel Macron va faire ses courses ça
doit pas être simple puis il rentre avec
tout ce qu'il ne faut pas et après c'est
un bazar dans la cuisine et puis voilà
au final il n'y arrivait pas trop il y a
une lectrice qui lui demande et alors ce
que c'est bon elle répond c'est élaboré